can you imagine Draco malfoya as a
Disney prince and did you know that
Ivana Lynch approved the design of a
disney-fied Luna we're breaking down
what Harry Potter would look like if it
were remade as an animated movie now
Harry Potter may be the boy who lived
but he wouldn't have gotten far without
Ron and Hermione there were other
friends at Hogwarts like Luna Lovegood
who helped Cherry get by of course but
we'll be getting to those in a moment
these three would serve as the heart to
our imagined little Disney movie here
and this fan art from deviant artist
John sketches stuff gives us a pretty
good idea of how they'd all look
together Harry has a certain Prince Eric
vibe to him here while Ron's design is
based off of Kristoff and Hermione takes
inspiration from Moana we also have to
show you this fan art from this deviant
artist that shows Ron and Hermione as
Belle and Beast which was just too cute
not to include does anybody else get
Yule Ball vibes from this Luna Lovegood
is practically a Disney character as it
is she's a free spirit who marches to
the beat of Her Own Drum and if that
isn't Disney princess material then we
don't know what is it's a charm actually
Ivana Lynch even praised this fan art of
a disney-fied version of Luna by mad
Boogie Creations to her Instagram page
according to her it really captures
Luna's soul and by that she meant her
dreaminess Whimsy curiosity Serenity and
depth and we can see it too Ivana just
look at those large eyes exactly like
Anna and Elsa's from Frozen you also get
a sense of Luna's total uniqueness in
this picture with her Specter specs on
top of her head she suits this design
almost as well as a certain potions
teacher we'll be discussing next Snape
is driven by his love for Lily after all
this time he's forever tormented by his
feelings for her sort of like a certain
Disney villain that he kinda reminds us
of just like Snape Prolo is also
compelled by his feelings for Esmeralda
choose me for the fire frollo also has
the same long nosesnape and his shallow
complexion as it's described in the
books just give him some long dark hair
and Hogwarts robes as deviant artist
gating has done and you already have the
perfect design for Snape right there
it's almost too perfect kind of like how
this may just be the perfect time for
you to hit that subscribe button if
you're enjoying our video because when
it comes to morally dubious characters
here we're just getting started Draco
Malfoy isn't what you'd call evil he's
just a bit of a bully and a little
arrogant because he was raised in a rich
family who used to be among Voldemort's
Death Eaters more on him later because
of this we're picturing a design that
plays on draco's nobility maybe even
going so far as to make fun of the
prince Trope the way that we saw Disney
do already in Into the Woods I was
phrased to be Charming not sincere for
our animated movie though we're thinking
of a design that's similar to what we
saw Disney do with Prince Philip like
the fan art from this deviant artist the
artist has given him draco's iconic
blonde hair and sense of Slytherin Pride
as well so we can definitely see
something like this working scared
Potter you wish Lord Voldemort is one of
the coolest villains out there he really
is the definition of evil which makes it
sort of hard for us to picture him
cracking jokes like a Weasley even still
we're taking our inspiration from a sort
of unlikely Source name is Hades Lord of
the Dead hi how you doing we don't see a
whole lot in common between arguably
Disney's funniest villain and he who
must not be named but this fan art shows
us just how horrifying the combination
can be Voldemort is described as looking
more snake-like than human the more that
he dabbles with dark magics in the book
anyway so something like this could
definitely go a long way towards making
him an imposing figure in our Disney
movie pass myself disappointed now Ginny
is one tough witch in the books she has
to be she had six big brothers to make
her that way if we're gonna have her in
a Disney movie then we're going to watch
to see her with a design that perfectly
captures that strength like this one
from another deviant artist it shows
Ginny with her quidditch goggles in
place her red hair a little Windswept
and a big smile on her face it seems to
say that she's up to no good just like
her brothers and of course you can see
that she's wearing her mother's knit
sweater because like many of our heroes
she's all about family at the end of the
day what animated Disney movie wouldn't
be complete without talking animals
Sirius Black is Harry Potter's godfather
who we honestly would have rather seen
raise hairy than the dursleys but more
on them in a bit because Sirius is also
an animagus capable of transforming
himself into a black dog at will we
imagine that Disney would have a field
day with this opportunity giving us
Sirius in his dog form in as many scenes
as possible the Prisoner of Azkaban
movies show series as a kind of scraggly
looking dog but you have to know that
Disney would clean him up a bit like
this deviant fan art from Flair and
icicle sure he's still a little bit
disheveled the artist did take
inspiration from open my eyes to
what a dog's life can really be but this
dog is still far friendlier looking than
the one Harry Miss took as an omen of
death originally you have Grim the
dursleys are described as being pretty
cartoonish in the books already petunia
is a thin woman with a long neck and
blonde hair with her husband Vernon a
beefy man with a bushy black mustache
and their son Dudley a chunky boy with
blonde hair who Harry describes as
looking a lot like a pig in a wig these
descriptions lend themselves well to the
Disney fight design of the Muggle family
by this deviant artist except
potentially for Dudley looking like a
pig in a wig you can also see ant Marge
floating away in the corner of the
picture which reminds us of the sort of
whimsical scenes that we really want to
see Disney revisit sorry
you can definitely see the magic
practiced at Hogwarts providing us with
a lot of whimsical Disney moments as
well especially when you get Dumbledore
involved now there are a lot of
similarities between Dumbledore and
Merlin when you think about it they're
both great Wizards and both of them go
on to Mentor young Heroes and they're
both known for wearing flowing magical
looking robes and they both have long
white beards just slap a pair of Half
Moon shaped glasses on that long nose
and you're already there sort of like
what this deviant artist has done here
we imagine a Disney version of Harry
Potter would probably use him to similar
effect as Merlin too playing the old and
wise Mentor getting up to magical
hijinks you can't grow up without a
decent education you know Dolores
Umbridge may be the most hated character
among the fandom I will have water in
the books she was described as a toad
like woman with a wide mouth and a
Velvet Bow in her hair that reminded
Harry of a fly about to be eaten it's a
great image for sure and this deviant
artist turned that description into an
image that could come straight out of
Disney just look at that evil
grinch-like smile it didn't have to be
this way Dolores all you had to do was
listen to Harry and maybe be a little
nicer to half Giants like our next entry
on the list umbridge's short and squat
stature remind us a little bit of Ursula
here though we imagine that she'd have
to throw a lot more pink into that
wardrobe Hagrid was made to be an
animated character his Larger than Life
features practically make him a cartoon
already a big part of Hagrid's design
would have to focus on the half Giant's
massive height compared to the students
at Hogwarts something that this digital
artist we found on Pinterest captured
well in this fan art you see how Hagrid
Towers over little Harry in an almost
similar way to how Baymax Towers over
hero over at Disney there here there
considering how gorgeous Hagrid's hair
looked in the picture we can definitely
see the animators having some fun here
the way they did designing Merida's hair
for brave Mad Eye Moody is not known for
his Beauty he needs a design that more
reflects the amount of dark Wizards he's
fought and this deviant artist has given
us a work of fan art that does that well
he looks almost a little bit like
Quasimodo from The Hunchback of Notre
Dame here and by emphasizing his
artificial eye so much the artist does a
great job of drawing your attention to
it without the massive eye attachment
from the movies and yet it's the
disfiguring scar that really gives this
face strength this artist also seems to
have drawn a bit of influence from
Disney characters like Preston B
Whitmore from Atlantis for this one
which definitely helps to lend Mad Eye
Moody an air of well-traveled
sophistication considering some of these
designs Harry Potter might just work
better as an animated movie than we'd
expect are there any other moments from
the book you'd like to see Disney handle
and which of these designs was your
favorite today we're all fans of magic
here so make sure to let us know in the
comment section down below